I spent a lot of time looking at foreign
models.
I actually
chaired this year,
the health governors at the World
Economic Congress in Davos and I'm the
current chair of the International
Federation of Health plans and health
plans from 80 countries around the
world.
And so I meet all the time with health
plans from,
from those other countries.
And I've been looking hard to figure out
which attributes of those plans would
fit in the US.
And one of the things I've learned from
working with all those countries is that
every single one does it a little
differently.
So the model in Germany looks a lot like
the Netherlands,
but it's not quite the same Austria
different than both those,
but the quite similar fact.
The model had governor Schwarzenegger
proposed in California last year looks
suspiciously like the Australian model,
uh,
that every country does it slightly
differently.
But if I were going to pick a model that
I think
would,
would transplant,
well,
it's actually the Dutch model.
I think the Dutch have done some really
good things and the thing that they have
added to their model more recently is a
risk adjuster between the health plan.
So when the health plans go out and
recruit members and enroll people,
uh,
the government in the end does a,
an assessment of who got the healthy
people who got the less healthy people
and if any health plan,
God,
a disproportionate number of healthy
people,
they have to actually pay some money
back into the pool.
And any health plan got too many sick
people.
They get more money from the pool.
And so what that does is strongly
encouraged,
as we were saying earlier,
the health plans to go after the sicker
people and do a really good job taking
care of sick people.
Because I know in the end they get
arrested the adjuster from the other
plants that enrolled healthier people.
So I think the Dutch model of having a
payroll deduction,
individual choice of health plans and
then the risk adjuster on the back end
has a lot to offer,
but it's a federal model.
They basically,
in the end of the year,
run the core information about each
health by how many diabetics do they
have,
how many congestive heart failure
patients,
how many asthmatic.
They sort through the whole thing,
and then basically when a formula and if
you have enrolled a disproportionate
number of people with those expensive
diseases in the high level of morbidity,
they increase your payment or if it's a
low level of decrease your payment,
and actually we do that to some degree
in this country on our Medicare
advantage program.
There's already we have a risk adjuster
formula that works in America.
It's a pretty good formula.
It's not perfect,
but it's a lot better than no formula,
and so we.
We already have a history of doing that.
We could.
I could adapt to the Dutch model
for.